today i wanted to share a few things
that we do to enjoy van life responsibly
we feel extremely grateful that there
are so many places around the country
that allow us to park our van overnight
for free
but unfortunately more often than not
we've pulled up to find these campsites
trashed
bottles cans and use toilet paper
everywhere we like to leave every spot
looking better than when we arrive so we
always keep a pair of gloves and
compostable bags in the van so that we
can tidy up before leaving
and we always make sure that we're
dumping in the appropriate designated
areas
we use an app called ioverlander to find
dump stations
do our best to avoid parking overnight
in big cities but when passing through
certain areas it can be hard to avoid
when looking for places to park
overnight we always read the signs
some cities have vehicle length and
height restrictions so depending on the
size of your van it could be worth it to
do a quick google search to make sure
you're in the clear before finding a
spot to park
before heading to our final spot for the
night we always make sure to put our
window covers on and do anything we need
to do outside of the van before we
arrive
when choosing a spot to park we always
try to avoid parking directly in front
of someone's home and opt for side
streets instead
we also avoid overly crowded streets to
avoid taking parking spots away from
residents
we always arrive late and leave early
and do our best to be quiet and
respectful
best case scenario no one will even know
we were there
downsizing to a van has given nate and i
the opportunity to finally get out of
debt and stop living paycheck to
paycheck
and we recognize the privilege that
comes with being able to choose this
lifestyle
we wanted to come up with a way that we
could give back to the communities in
the areas that we travel to
so we came up with a plan we added up
all the money we've saved on rent so far
and calculated a percentage to put away
to donate each month
we make a monthly contribution to this
website that helps us acknowledge and
learn about the native land that we'll
be traveling on
and when traveling through cities we
look for community care organizations
that we can donate to
today i'm going to tell you guys about
the propane system in our van our
propane system powers things like our
two burner stove
our heater and our on-demand water
heater which allows us to take nice hot
showers and wash dishes a little more
easily
our propane tank is located inside the
driver's side bench
for safety it's in a sealed box that's
vented to the outside of the van and we
also have a propane detector
we use a 5 gallon propane tank that we
only have to switch out every few months
i'm gonna
[Music]
i'm gonna lay here
[Music]
the clouds will
[Music]
will
disappear
you